crise du golf peut être en passe d'être
résolu un conflit qui oppose depuis
trois ans et demi le qatar à l'arabie
saoudite et trois de ses alliés arabes
le bahreïn l'egypte et les émirats
arabes unis l'information a été rendue
publique après les déclarations
optimistes du cher ar mais nasser al
mohammad al sabah le ministre des
affaires étrangères du koweït des
discussions fructueuses ont eu lieu où
toutes les parties ont affirmé leur
attachement à la solidarité et la
stabilité du golfe et des pays arabes et
à la conclusion d'un accord final qui
réalise la solidarité permanente aspirer
entre leurs pays
le chef de la diplomatie koweïtienne a
également remercié les membres de
l'administration trump le président
américain sortant s'est félicité de
cette nouvelle par la voix de son
secrétaire d'état
mike pompe et nous espérons que le
différend entre les saoudiens et les
canaris pourra être résolue nous
l'espérons car nous pensons que c'est
important pour la paix dans tout le
moyen-orient
mais surtout nous pensons que c'est la
bonne chose pour les populations de ces
pays
oui nous allons continuer à faire ce que
nous pouvons pour faciliter les
conversations et le dialogue
là où nous pouvons aider nous sommes
impatients de le faire le bahreïn
l'egypte l'arabie saoudite et les
émirats arabes unis avaient rompu leurs
liens avec le qatar le 5 juin 2010 est
juste après un sommet à riyad au cours
duquel les dirigeants du golfe avait
rencontré donald trump le royaume
wahhabite avait convaincu ses alliés de
prendre cette décision affirmant que le
petit émirat était trop proche de l'iran
et qu'ils finançaient des mouvements
islamistes radicaux
accusation que doha a toujours démenti
les quatre partenaires ont alors chassé
des qatari qui résidaient sur leur sol
est imposé à l'état incriminé un blocus
maritime terrestre et aérien une
décision qui a été prise malgré les
liens du pays avec les états unis
près de dix mille soldats américains
sont hébergés à la base aérienne d'al ou
dead en plein coeur du qatar une base
qui abrite notamment un quartier général
avancé du commandement central de
l'armée américaine